the fans enjoyed hearing mike perlman
come on the show to antagonize ronnie
the pearlman slash ronnie dynamic works
this listener reminds me mike for the
love of god now that it's been so many
years
tell the truth did you [ __ ] with
ronnie's bagel he loves to [ __ ] with me
because he thinks everything is a big
joke what's the joke if someone messes
with you this is the [ __ ] joke the
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass up this is a
[ __ ] joke
absolutely not
no
and what was it again i forget the story
just give it to me briefly it was bagel
wednesday and he has this process where
he takes a bagel he goes into the green
room where he had a little desk and then
he'd take a bunch of paper towels and
wrap up the paper towels yeah this
particular day he happened to walk away
for a couple of minutes and he came back
there was nothing but a napkin on top of
his bagel and what i think happened was
he put the napkin on and that's all he
did he didn't do the whole process of
wrapping it up listen to me okay here's
how it goes down with me there okay okay
okay every bagel wednesday
i would get my bagel
there was irish butter and i would put
some on i wouldn't eat it right away
i'd wrap it up
yeah it's fascinating because you would
[ __ ] come down and sneak around and
study this [ __ ] i would come
down and study my [ __ ] routine i mean
listen we could sit here and and divulge
in the conspiracies i didn't touch your
baby i'm such a [ __ ] lunatic i swear
to god but but ronnie what a lame prank
he could never look me straight in the
eye and tell me
that he didn't do it mike okay stare
straight in his eye and tell him the
truth i take those lights off mike you
have full immunity i'm telling you now
let's stop this look at the smirk on it
because i'm smiling at how ridiculous
you sound yeah okay i sound ridiculous i
mean to [ __ ] with your bagel man i mean
that's a big offense
[Laughter]
no i know what i know what mike is
saying you don't you know what a weird
prank to just put a napkin over it like
like why not just take a bite out of it
or move it somewhere and hide it dude he
was laughing the whole [ __ ] time
that's how i delay for him no matter
what he's like that type of guy right
where you look at him you just start
laughing like you know like yeah
he's hitting him in that compound he's
got the pink shirt on with the t-shirt
underneath
he's got a suit on he's all angry he's
pissed off he's cursing right everybody
okay
he's got his own show going on in the
hallway we just pulled the staff 92
percent of people think ronnie just
forgot that paper towel is bagel good
for them that's i'm very happy for them
what they think pearlman was always up
to [ __ ] upstairs on 37. always always
wheeling and dealing these little
[ __ ] games hey guys you know what i
just did downstairs i just made a
[ __ ] bit like you wouldn't believe
it's gonna go on for years he's got his
own he's got his own thing in his head
like his whole scenario when you know
what went down all right jd wants to get
on with a statement he wants to read
from the employee who thinks mike [ __ ]
with ronnie's bagel jd you were handed
this by the person who agrees with
ronnie the one person
two people have come forward two people
all right
one says i remember perlman coming off
as very suspicious that morning
no solid evidence just came off as a guy
who got caught doing something stupid
and trying to cover up a mistake i'm on
team ronnie okay the second person says
ronnie and perlman were talking about it
and i could tell that perlman did it and
i saw a couple of security guards
laughing also it's the kind of mind game
pearlman would play but he's smart not
to say anything today gotta commit to
the bid in a way i wish i had done it
it makes sense see
those two statements make perfect sense
everybody's possessed that's [ __ ]
pearlman
ronnie uh thank you and mike perlman
thank you and uh the controversy but i
guess we'll continue yeah ronnie's never
going to believe him never never
yeah little prick